gráfica x menor que 4 así que voy a
dibujar la recta numérica a ver veamos
aquí está la recta numérica
digamos que aquí voy a poner 0 luego
continuó 1 2 3 4 15 y claro podría
continuar ahora voy a poner los
negativos
aquí está menos 1 1 - 2 - 3 menos cuatro
para graficar x menor que 4 voy a poner
un círculo en el 4
esto quiere decir que el 4 no está
incluido si el 4 estuviera incluido
pondría un punto sólido o un círculo con
relleno pero en este caso no está
incluido y después voy a colorear todos
los números que son menores que 4
y todos los que son menores que 4 y
obviamente incluyendo la flecha
y entonces ahora tenemos todos los
números que son menores que cuatro de
color azul y podemos comprobarlo por
ejemplo si yo tomo el menos 2 que está
aquí pues menos 2 naturalmente es menor
que 4 lo mismo ocurre con el 1 o con el
3 y ya no ocurre con 4 porque 4 no es
menor que 4 y 5 tampoco es menor que 4